you can't know what you don't know but I
do think that President Bush getting it
so wrong on weapons of mass destruction
exposed more than him it exposed the
entire press corps and that has opened
up I think a huge media landscape to
people people across the political
spectrum
conservative Republicans progressives
independents Democrats people care about
war about corporate control about
privacy and I think the media getting so
wrong getting it also wrong in this
lead-up to the invasion has made people
look other places and that's why
independent media is so important right
now I think it's why democracy now has
grown so much from a few dozen community
radio stations in 1996 the first daily
election show in public broadcasting to
over 700 stations now community stations
yes low-power college and community
radio stations pacifica stations now NPR
stations PBS stations the two
independent TV channels on the on the
satellites on Dish Network free speech
TV and link TV both on DirecTV and Dish
Network and the reason I say all this
it's not so easy to you know say oh we
broadcast on NBC or ABC that's what a
big network that's all you have to say
but we are building an independent media
network in this country linking up with
independent stations all over the world
and they are coming from every different
sector and so we have to include them
all when we talk about what is
independent media but people are looking
other places of course to the web as
well and for us it's democracynow.org
but I think independent media's time has
come because people see young and old
what it means when the media has a
corporate agenda how dangerous it is
when our image is projected to the rest
of the world through a corporate lens I
mean if you look at the way the rest of
the world sees us and the way we see
ourselves I think that is very telling
if you ask someone what they think is
the most famous image of the invasion I
dare say that someone in this country
would probably say the image of Saddam
Hussein the Statue going down because we
saw thousands of times remember April
9th 2003 fear doe square in Baghdad you
see that rope around his neck just
outside the frame or the US Marines
pulling it down but anyway it goes down
and then up down up down thousands of
times we all remember it because the
media showed it the rest of the world
was showing something different or at
least something additional actually The
Wall Street Journal did a piece on this
and they looked at didn't compare CNN
and al-jazeera they compared CNN with
itself because CNN you know has two
channels at at CNN domestic and CNN
international and they pull from the
same pool of picture CNN domestic just
kept showing that Statue going up and
down up and down but CNN International
knew they couldn't get away with that
because the rest of the media was
showing the casualties of war so they
showed a split screen on one side the
Statue going up and down on the other
the casualties of war we need a media
that tells the truth because when there
is so much media so many channels out
there you somehow get the feeling if
something is happening you would know
about it and so it actually I think
makes us less informed I think that if
we were to see for one week the images
of war if we saw the babies dead on the
ground in Iraq the women would their
legs blown off by cluster bombs from
Iraq to Afghanistan to Lebanon if we saw
the soldiers dead and dying for just one
week Americans would say no that war is
not the answer to conflict in the 21st
if we saw it in the front page of our
newspapers all the photographs we saw at
the top stories of our newscasts or any
of them I mean President Bush the Bush
administration knows the power of these
images that's why one of their first
acts was to impose an executive order
that said you're not to film photograph
videotape the flag-draped coffins of
soldiers coming home you know
when Hurricane Katrina hit in New
Orleans one of the administration's
first acts if they engaged in anything
was to try to impose that order that
you're not to show the images of bodies
floating by the editor of the
times-picayune said you've got to be
kidding you know that's the story they
know the power of Americans seeing
Americans dead or frankly Americans
seeing people dead you know when you
know the name of a little girl I don't
care if she's American or Iraqi it
sometimes counts more than hearing the
number 1 million hurt the newspapers
kept showing that target on the forehead
of Saddam Hussein but that's not who
dies in a war more accurate would have
been a target on the forehead of a
little Iraqi girl I think that would
have changed the way Americans made a
decision about whether we should go